welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and badge streets batch you're right
we're gonna be completely honest with
you yeah we're already scraping the
barrel with the intros
and we've got six episodes left so i'm
genuinely panicking about how bad it's
gonna get
that being said episode 10 of the bad
batch is now here
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down the plot easter eggs
things you missed and also giving out
theories on what could be happening next
time
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the show then
say
jedi night night as we're spoiling it
all
smash the thumbs up button if you're the
ob one left who still likes my puns
and make sure you subscribe for brand
new breakdowns every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the bad batch
episode 10.
okay so last episode we watched as cad
bane made his way across the galaxy with
his prisoner omega
she didn't know what toto until toto
popped up and she tricked him into
letting her free so that she could
escape
cad had been contracted to track down
omega so that her cells could be used
for the kaminoans to create more clones
as it turned out her dna structure was
one of the strongest strains of fat left
outside of her brother boba however
there was a sort of split amongst the
cameron owens
and we learned that fenix shand had two
being hired to keep her safe
cad headed to boroville and shout outs
ryan airy who translated the obesh
letters that showed that a critical
issue had happened in the structures
that made the kaminoans flee in escape
pods now here shannon bane went head to
head
and the former somewhat explained to
omega exactly why she was wanted
luckily omega managed to reach out to
the batch and she was saved by them
there were a couple of big mysteries
left up in the air and though i know a
lot of you think that snow clones were
in the containers
i do think that these were simply
cameron owens i don't have the name of
the person on the video as i didn't
screenshot
but someone did point out that they as a
species have been reduced to
manufacturing
each other in order to live so give
yourself a pat on the back if that was
you
and in fact you know what everyone give
themself a pat on the back for sitting
through my crap videos for 10 weeks
now as for episode 10 this entry is
called common ground
and it has the batch having their
ideologies challenged as they realize
that not everything is as black and
white as a stormtrooper's uniform
as george lucas said there are heroes on
both sides
which is there though any anyway we pick
up on raxus or
raxus secundus to give it its full name
this is a planet that was often
contested throughout the clone wars
and it's clear that this is carried over
to the galactic empire as the imperials
are angered that they've remained in the
confederacy of independent
planets during the clone wars dooku set
up these systems as ones that would be
free from the corrupt republic
and originally genosis was their first
capital however after it fell
raxis took its place and it became a
collective for those that didn't want to
join the republic
now there's several characters here
including senator avi singh
and his droid which you may recognize as
being an ra-7 model
there's also some pantorans amongst the
crowd as well as a rodian
which is the same species as greedo
singh's hands are tied
and this symbolically is shown by sin
clasping his hands together however he
opens them up in an act of defiance
against the imperials
and refuses to join their ranks he sees
it as his duty to act in the best
interests of raxis
and there's a lot of similarities here
between the nazi occupation of europe
which led to their forces invading
countries throughout the second world
war
they had the numbers and the might and
here we see this echoed in the imperials
who circle the square with att's gs8
reaches out for help and we cut to omega
and wrecker eating some mantel mix
the pair's favorite snack that has
bonded them throughout the series
they're cautious about taking jobs when
there's at least two bounty hunters
gunning for omega
and reluctantly they get one from sid
that involves rescuing sing
sid ends up babysitting a mega but
knowing how much he charges
you should have used princess superstar
instead now now that's a joke kids
because
because in the 2000s there was a rapper
called princess superstar that had a
song about being a bad babysitter
go listen to it yeah it'll really open
your eyes
now omega clearly feels that she's been
left behind and she's immediately forced
into child labour to clean the toilets
i bet sid didn't pay her for this and in
the bar we can once more see the digital
spock machine
which mimics the main card game in the
star wars universe
go to the batch flying taraxis and they
land outside the capital city of
raxillon
which just so happens to be the home of
their senate
things have really changed for the batch
as when they were enlisted as clone
troopers
they were fighting against separatists
but now due to their shifting ideologies
they're aiding members of the group they
always thought they'd reach the planet
one day
but that they'd be going as an army
instead of as mercenaries
echo clearly has issues working for the
separatists and this is made worse by
the fact they learn that their contact
is a droid
in the star wars universe droids are
very much viewed as the peasant class
that aren't allowed in bars or certain
parts of society
even last week todo was hinting that
cadbane was cruel to him
and rise of skywalker had d.o clearly
being a droid that was abused
the mandalorian hated them as well and
you can see why echo is cautious
but come on guys yeah they're lovely now
cut back to sids bar
and we see the ithorian and weak way
once more playing hollow chess
i love how these guys have slowly become
background characters
that are almost set dressing for the
place and every time we see them they
get in more and more trouble
a fight breaks out between them this
time and sid herself causes some issues
when she pretty much says that omega is
about as useful as this channel
i think omega kind of feels a bit let
down by the batch and even though they
had her best interests at heart
she sees herself as being capable enough
to handle things on her own
cut back to raxis and gs8 leads the
batch into the capital
there's very similar vibes here to the
occupation of naboo from the phantom
menace
and they scan the area before taking the
stealth approach
i love how you can see the clear
contrasting colours between their
uniforms and the clones now
as they are in black and white
showcasing how they view the galaxy
whereas the batches are grey showing
that they view the galaxy as being
shades of that
this idea of color has been used
throughout the saga often with luke
who started off wearing white then grey
before going fully to black
highlighting his character progression
the groups sneak in
and interestingly hunter gives orders
that include omega
showing that he subliminally views her
as being part of the team
even though he left her behind we go to
the ball and see omega has the same
comms device
that luke had in a new hope and sid
plays hollow chest
very very badly now here you can also
see some
some pipes i want to say pipe things and
these also showed up in the bar in a new
hope
interestingly they were reused for the
head of ig-88
one of the most fearsome bounty hunters
in the galaxy
sid sees a little opportunity to make
some money in a mega
and it basically becomes a mix of rain
man and the queen amidala's gambit
now in sings wine cellar the imperials
led by captain bragg
send in an interrogation droid which we
also see in a new hope
using stun blasts the batch managed to
rescue him
but unfortunately the alarm is sounded
and they have to fight their way out of
there
i love how gsa carries the priceless
vars the entire time
and it shows they still hold their
independence very very highly
it leads to by far one of the best
action scenes in the show
and no matter how many transports and
troops the imps are at them
they managed to escape with a little
help of a certain boss
after jacking in att they take the
subterranean passage
and manage to escape through the tunnels
of the city on the outskirts they make
it to the ship
but singh realizes that he's abandoning
his people clearly he wrestles with this
but after ekko says
live to fight another day it changes his
mind now this is something that hardcase
said when sacrificing himself in the
episode plan of descent
and i'm still i still miss him so much
though back on odd mantel
omega and sid run the hollow chest ring
and she beats a pantoran
making her the most feared hollow chess
player in the galaxy
this angus hunter a bit as he wanted her
to keep a low profile
but she earned enough to pay off the
debt that they owed sid sid clearly
believed in her
even though hunter didn't and it shows
him that she is more than he thinks
they play one more match for whether
she'll set out on missions or not
and spoiler alert we know that hunter
got
wrecked anyway another great episode and
probably
one of the stronger ones in the series
so far as it had a lot going on with it
in terms of metaphor
and the group wrestling with their
opposing ideologies
also i just want to apologize if my
voice is sounding terrible this video
i've got very bad hay fever at the
moment so sorry if i sound like i've
just woken up
which i also have now as for my thoughts
on the show so far i've
really really enjoyed how they've slowly
brought everything together to make it
crystal clear
while the empire could take over at the
moment the rebellion isn't anywhere near
assembled
and through the batch we've seen how
everything is just off in its own little
faction
the imperials are the only thing that
are organized right now and then
blindsiding the jedi in order to wipe
them out
left a big power vacuum that they've
been able to step into and seize control
from
the fact that the bats have been going
from person to person shows why it was
so easy for the empire to rule
because they were the only ones who were
organized now what we've had in the
series are free people who are gonna
fight day to day
in order to survive versus people like
cross air who handed over their freedom
in order to have a role in society and
probably things more comfortable
though he does get shot out a lot now
he's very much disposable
but either way i love how this series is
tackling themes like this
the bad batch has been great so far and
to be 10 episodes deep with this level
of quality in an animated property
shows how much of a boss that felony is
another excellent entry
and i can't wait to see what happens in
the next one now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as to thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of july
in which you pick three random comments
to win an mcu box set of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of loki episode 4 which will
be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for singing
through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace